hello and welcome to another now playing
I'm here with Bonito Gonzalez that's
Eric tay we're going to play some
xenonauts today do you know what
xenonaut is Eric I know because you've
been hyped this whole like last week or
so um I know it's a game that's very
very similar to original XCOM which is
why you're so hyped about it yes I love
original XCOM it was one of my I guess
it's on my top 10 list of all-time best
games ever okay and uh xenonauts is a
very very you know truthful remake of
this game I mean I like the old XCOM and
be unknown don't get me wrong was okay I
have about 90 hours so I can't complain
yeah but this game when I started it up
I was like oh [__] this is this is XCOM
so let's take a look at it let's go yeah
there you go there we go so like let's
start with a new game Let's uh I'm going
I'm going to start with a new game to
show everybody how hard it is so like
you seeing the normal you have to be if
you're not an x-com veteran you should
to play on normal but I am an x-com
veteran so I'm going to play on veteran
oh look your little uh your rank went up
on the on the guy too see on the guy you
got some you got some Stripes some
Stripes uh yeah so the game of Beau
aliens are dangerous and The Invasion
escalates quickly I turn off the tool
tips I'll turn those on for you guys
okay oh they also have the Iron Man mode
which that's like one save you get one
save it auto saves for you you can't
save yourself and yeah that's just
really hard I don't do that but I do my
own sort of like the very XCOM thing
right the Iron Man that's like your next
level that's your like next level kind
of like new game plus I guess kind of
all you know if you want like the extra
challenge okay all right okay so if
anybody has not played an xcong game
before this game has a lot of levels to
it there's like a lot of things to this
game you have your geoscape management
so first I have to put my base down I
usually select AF Africa because there's
like a lot of land cuz if you shoot an a
UFO down uhhuh over water you don't get
to fight it you don't get to get the
aliens and all that [__] okay all right
so you want a a large land mass and
covering a lot of countries so because
every year you get like a budget report
I don't know if and that's something you
can't actually access that's one of the
things that pissed me off about this
game in the old game you could access
see like how much people are giving you
and how much they want to take away so
here Northern Sahara let's the northern
Sahara so why is China not like a better
China's good too China's cool I usually
put my second base in China all
right um okay so this is the geoscape
map where like you'll see you'll see
these four up here these are the times
like we're we're going at normal time
right now so you see the time passing
you know relatively slow two three 1 two
3 4 goes through the time speeds so
there you see like the daytime and the
night time so if you if you if you
attack an alien during the daytime it's
the daytime night that kind of thing and
does that affect your like combat at all
or anything like visibility or
visibility so at night aliens can have
normal visibility but you have reduced
visibility okay so you don't want to
fight at night so here we go we got one
UFO detected right there see so I want
to intercept it with my convers and in
the original XCOM you could only send
one plane uhhuh to go attack it now you
can send multiple so I'm going to send
two to attack this what is it a small so
that's like a scout ship I don't need to
send two but I'm just in case some
independence day going on here there we
go the light Scout and then here you can
also autoresolve the combat now okay and
uh that's usually good when you want to
just like get through it because it's an
easy fight but I'll show you the what
the air combat looks like now you don't
control this right can you can I'm not
controlling it right now like but I can
see like I can select that plane see
right now they're on like interception
course right so this plane I'm going to
say go that way oops whoa go that way
flank him go that
way see so this guy's going to flank him
okay
bam so I'm guessing there are other
scenarios where where you run into like
multiple UFOs there's like mother ships
that have like Scouts with them click on
it there you go do you ever get
outnumbered oh God uh you can oh God
okay wait I'm going pause that cuz I
screwed
up oh God they're going to take one of
my Condors down Condor too okay no he
survived see so I took him
down into the sea though he crashed into
is the sea he crashed into the sea this
you don't you don't you can't I can't is
this the sea I don't think it's the sea
okay I don't know it just said crash
into the sea is where oh it is the sea
yeah you're right so yeah so that sucks
yeah I think I still got stuff out of it
and that like I protected the
surrounding region but I don't get to do
the Tactical combat part and we'll get
into the base stuff when I get into you
know because this is how I play the game
okay okay so I just completed my first
research which is the tech side of this
game uhuh here's the research screen
right now I can only research these two
things this is like the little tank this
is like a new plane so let's do that
plane oh and if anybody got questions in
the chat Eric's reading the chat
and in the beginning you always want to
hire at least like five new scientists
or else Tech goes really slowly and you
see like you have lab space and you have
living space and that's all connected to
the
base where you know you have your
workshop and that's for engineers you
have that's the build stuff is that like
a blimp what is that thing on the top
left the top left oh that's your uh
that's the drop ship that holds your
dudes all right like the
dudes you're uh you're you get to repair
your planes too right like your Condor
to yeah you repair but it's it all it's
like Auto it it just happens so it's not
like damaged the next time you go out to
fight it is let's see what happen let's
see what my ples look like right now
oops actually I can't can
I can I oh yeah there see you can see at
low Health this one's still hurt they're
repairing it this one's okay and there's
fuel also an ammo okay so you might not
send the other one next time maybe okay
and it'll tell you in the screen when
you're trying to intercept it if it's
still damaged so let's make make some
time pass here a lot of the game is this
like oh there there's the
UFO see there it'll tell you you know oh
okay so they're back to normal yeah so
they're back to full oh chased them down
I'm just going to autor resolve these
because I suck at the air
combat see took no damage good it's like
Madden but it's over the ocean again
okay fine I'm going to take down I got
to take down this next one yo let your
Defenders take care of it you don't you
don't try to do it yourself or they're
going to score yeah no
[__] so that the whole night cycle thing
is kind of tripping me out though just
how it goes through the M it it makes me
think like is something wrong with the
TV oh man I'm going to need to Infinity
wants to know uh have you finished the
campaign yet I have not I'm actually on
my third playthrough because I screwed
up massively the first two times I
played it's one of those games where you
can screw up in the beginning and not
know it until I hours later so it's one
of those games just to be warned okay
lot of Tri by fire yeah a lot of that uh
I can now build this
little tank but I can't because I don't
have a
garage so the little garage okay so the
rest of your grid is five days yeah so
everything takes up pretty much two
spots or one spot and then you have
space for all these bases I think it's
what eight you can have eight bases
total wow what's the most bases you've
had so far so far too okay yeah fair
enough and you know you can specialize
the bases to do stuff or
uh but the first base is normally like
to do everything base because you have
to do everything out of that base in the
beginning and for the first couple of
months you're only going to live on one
base until you take down a couple of
ships and make some money like right now
I could already build a second base but
I'll probably be
broke you can't sustain right like you
can't sustain okay so what like for for
a complete novice of like XCOM games for
like my myself or anyone else watching
like what is your ultimate end goal here
you have to you have to beat the alien
invasion you have to beat them back cuz
right now like a time thing yeah so see
at the bottom right there's your
objective you're always given like these
little objectives that are kind
of they're they're not random like there
is a real trajectory to it but they they
seem like small things you know they're
like you know you know crash uh crash
say secure crash UFO cuz that's usually
when you crash a UFO and you like beat
them you get all their Tech and start
searching that but we've been fighting
over the sea yeah we been fighting over
the ocean so hasn't been working out so
well and I can load up a game a save
later on which is like a little bit
later in the game you can see that
stuff okay see I've already done all my
research because I haven't downed a UFO
Overland yet so I'm wasting a bun
research right like I'm probably already
screwed this game's probably already
screwed oh really yeah just by virtue
luck because of the first two no it's
not bad luck I could have waited to
intercept those until they overl but I
just
Oh Oh see now there's two there's two oh
does your squadron break off properly I
can make
them see I can oh no there's a squadron
I can break the Squadron then I'd have
to send him individually but I want to
send both of them to this UFO cuz it's a
little bigger than this one I think this
is a fighter and this is a scout you can
tell by the very small and the speed
usually okay oh they the speed yeah this
is the speed so do you have to kill it
within that c like your circle cuz that
represents like your base right no that
Circle represents your radar oh just you
can't see anything outside of there but
your planes can actually go further they
have fuel and fuel tells tells you how
long how far away they can go so if you
like crashed it in the South part of
Africa you just have to Traverse really
far to get the parts and stuff well like
this the the drop ships can go
everywhere okay there I took one down
over land in the daytime this is ideal
okay okay so now we have to configure
our dudes that are going to go kill him
all right right all right so first off
actual combat yeah outside of fig the
drop ship I have eight dudes that's
eight dudes always feels like really
unwieldy to me because there's too many
mhm and you can uh you can sort these by
okay so okay so this is another part of
the game this is like the RPG part of
the game where each of the units have
stats Yep this is time units that's how
much they can move like how many yeah
time SES hit points strength which is
how much they can carry and the size of
the weapons they can use um accuracy
which is obvious reflex which
is like if you have extra time units
left at the end of a turn you can save
them and the reflex the reflex is like
an initiative count between you and the
enemy and if you have a higher reflex
count then you can shoot first if you
have enough time and bravery is just
like morale because they can freak out
in combat it's like cuz that happens in
XCOM Enemy I know as well so what I
usually do is I take the guys with the
best accuracy with me because you need
to kill dudes and I only bring six uh I
got another question from Affinity uh so
does the tech tree give you anything
interesting eventually yes like what
though what kind what's interesting to
you because it's all pretty interesting
to me keep going we'll get the follow
question you get your laser guns you get
your plasma guns I haven't seen anything
past plasma yet in this game okay so so
there you go I I picked my oh that's
seven there's my six dudes that have you
know all no that's Richards man he's got
64 time unit squares or whatever it does
oh 6 yeah you're right I should probably
take him let this by time units and see
what's up oh I definitely want to take
Richards all right I'm learning already
just looking at numbers yeah that's what
it's all I a lot of this game is just
like it's Resource Management you know
and it's numbers
basically Dolph
Winkler so I got a Rifleman heavy
weapons a Rifleman a sniper Rifleman
okay and now you can configure where
they are in the
plane that also matters that kind kind
it kind of matter it doesn't super
matter and in the old XCOM you can only
go out the back anyway but now you got
these side doors okay so I usually
put my shotgun
guy where's the shotgun guy he's front
yeah by the door in the back Machine Gu
is in the middle and that ballistic
rifle precision rifle that's the sniper
rifle there I usually do something like
that I usually have a tank also so this
guy can you'll see you'll see I'll
explain it when we get to the let we get
to the game all right here we go now we
send it
out Charlie
W oh [__] did they come attack you yeah
that doesn't really happen usually but
that plane went see so this other UFO
went to intercept my interceptors that
were going back to the base so let's see
what happens oh I can Auto resolve and
win
so oh you
barely barely made it out that was close
Okay return to base cuz were they 100%
after that last fight or were they Dam
yeah they were 100% but there were no
ammo okay so had to fight with machine
guns a real
fight
okay oh see so that that one I just
screwed it I just like screwed that
plane up and I just got retrieved stuff
from it and I didn't have to fight it so
no aliens survive that one basically
okay is that uh is it better to have
them survive uh it depends you know okay
cuz like there are times when you have
like six UFOs going at the same time you
have to decide which ones to leave or
which ones to fight and if you don't
have enough planes oops all right now
let's go to the meat of the game this is
the meat of the game right
here oh I forgot to rename I forgot to
rename my soldiers I was going to rename
them for chat dudes oh you could so is
it only the first
time I I just can't do it in game in in
combat if you want to die if you want to
sacrifice you because that's what
happens to people you don't pick people
you care about because they're generally
going to die okay so there's lots of
general rules to this game okay first
rule ABC always be crouching always be
crouching Pro tips from Bonito if you
guys are going to get into this game how
much is this game sorry oh yeah this is
$25 on Steam right now it's not on the
Steam Sale because it just came out uh
June 16th like a week ago all right okay
so first thing I always do is stand out
my shotgun guy just so cuz he has to he
has to be up
front and walk slowly and look around
cuz you're going to die if you don't do
that Pro tip number two yeah you're not
crouching though not yet oh okay you
just mean like after you're okay but see
okay here's the thing see there's my
time units I had 19 and it tells you
when you click on stuff when you click
like where that tells you how many you
have left if you do it okay it's not how
much you not how much you're spending
yeah it's how much you've got left that
kind of confused me in the beginning but
now I really like it
so you don't have to do the math in your
head um and here it tells you how how
many time units it takes to do like X
kind of shot so this gu a shot he has a
snap in a normal shot and he's really
low
range so you can see like if you hit
hold control down you can see like your
accuracy and your range see that yellow
it starts getting less
accurate okay so that guy I can't be
crouching because I want to save the
time units for a snapshot if he can take
it so I will break my own rule right now
but that's that's Advanced account
advanced advanced strategy oh all
right you have to know when to break the
rules that's like what was rule to again
uh always look around always look around
that's what I
thought see there's the dude right there
hey why don't you stop oh [__] okay it's
okay car is in the way yeah okay so
there's a dude right there I bet you
there's a dude around this corner too
and probably around here
somewhere so we will take cover behind
the car
see block 45% that means you have a 45%
chance of hitting that thing in front of
him and only a 17% chance of hitting him
okay and you use a scroll wheel to see
the different kinds of shots and
different accuracies but I can't afford
it too many time units yeah 18 to and I
have 23 so I can Crouch and and
crouching also increases your accuracy
by like 10% 20% sense something like
that uh is there a character limit on
your renames what do you mean oh can you
go Danny shot I'm pretty sure the limit
is like up to the end of this line right
here that's pretty long though yeah all
right so I'm not going to take the shot
yet because I want someone else might
have a better shot like my sniper
guy who's in the back and can't make it
yet okay
fine okay so Mouser Madness kind of
brings up a good point he says like
since this game is $25 right he thinks
it's A Hard Sell because you can you can
get the complete XCOM for less than that
it's true like uh yeah I mean I can see
that $25 like to be honest when I saw it
for $25 I was like $25 that's a bit Ste
then I started playing I was like okay
sure okay I'll pay $25 for gra is oh
basically for the graphics basically
like a graphical update and they removed
some of the some of the [__] minutia
like you don't have to make like
magazines anymore you know you don't
have to make grenades anymore because
you used to have to make all that
yourself and if you didn't know like the
parameters and the numbers you usually
make too much or too little
yeah and so some of that stuff they they
added some stuff too
okay okay this guy has no shot and
nothing fing so he's going to
crouch can my sniper make it take a shot
to any
no oh this is going to be bad it's one
dude Bonito yeah that one dude he has a
plasma rifle and I still have machine
guns well then we got to steal that gun
you got to become the
Eraser you just got to take cover we
just got to take cover for now
oops he doesn't look very alien though
this guy if I was to say yeah if I was
to he's a gray make a gripe he looks
almost like your guys yeah he's he's one
of many many different kinds of aliens
in this game oh [__] I'm blocking the
thing there's the time units
thing oh we might need to move us guys
like float us across make a little
smaller it would be that way actually
you can put on can put on the other side
on the other side too okay yeah side
would be fine because it's just your end
turn yeah okay I take a long time
playing these games just to let you all
know I I consider every option so this
hour long is going to be one battle
against one I wanted this to be a 4H
hour long stream cuz that's how much
time you need well we could have made a
pro tip video oh there we go W all right
made it to the other
side okay now I'm going to take these
shots I'm GNA take these shots they're
not going to be good shots but I'm going
to take
them you
missed 20% one in five chance see the
thing is I I can shoot now or I can hang
out and see if he moves and he'll take a
shot better when he's not in cover but I
don't know if he move he might just
shoot at me so I think I'm just going to
shoot I'm just going to
shoot rolling the dice oh man so here we
go we're going to watch someone die
really yeah guaranteed watch someone's
going to die isn't his percentage like
the same as yours at least in that
position he and he's got a better gun
than I do okay so this hidden movement
all the aliens and civilians that are
around or moving around that you can't
see oh he's shooting a civilian what a
yeah he's trying to kill a civilian so
every time you lose a civilian or like a
militia guy or whatever you lose money
at the end so at the end of every
Mission you get like a score so what's
worse losing a person or
money uh a dude what it depends on the
dude these guys are all noobs so it
doesn't really matter yet like later L
on when you have experienced guys and it
really hurts to lose
them okay this guy's screwed now I'm
going to kill this guy now all right
Aina which I've been butchering sorry I
always said Affinity I'm guessing it's
affan if that's wrong too I don't know
he said the first one was wrong anyways
um he says it doesn't really look like
Africa North Africa you know come on
come on what not all of Africa is the
desert there's cities in Africa come on
come
on
thought you were going to kill this guy
I I tried W you can hit him from that
95% where sniper man my sniper is hiding
but oh one shot he's dead one shot
that's all it took this guy hit him too
oh okay does a plasma rifle one shot it
depends on the dudes okay like those
guys are weak there's crit in this game
too right there is crit
okay always look around always be
looking before you walk into a room look
at
it so there's there's the ship there's
the ship so there's potential for
another alien so what you have to do is
you have to enter the ship kill all the
aliens in the ship and if there are
still aliens on the map all you have to
do is hold the ship for five turns and
then you win oh really so you don't even
have to engage yeah or kill all the
aliens that's the other way you can win
I usually just kill all the aliens cuz
you just try to anyway okay and you want
to scout the whole map because you don't
want to be trying to enter the ship and
he only comes from behind and kills you
cuz that happened to me many
times so these tips he's giving you are
from his lessons from his own
hard-earned lessons I'm saving you some
time oh God this is this is the part
that's really scary when you're moving
across the map to this dark Zone and
this is when people die this is when
people
die good thing he hasn't renamed any of
these to the co-workers but he will
rename them to the people in chat if you
guys want
dud so they can root for
themselves I'll root for their death or
they can tell me what they want to do oh
that's going to take too long yeah it'll
take too long there's too much delay
unless you're watching on hit boox I
don't even know if that delay is that
much better it's like marginally better
and I don't I don't think I don't even
know if Dan did it there all right let's
watch some dudes die
you think that they're I always feel
like someone's going to die that's why
that's good actually always expect the
worst healthy fear so so you don't get
to see them unless they come into your
line in my line of sight yeah which is
all like the illuminated stuff see so
all this like Shadow stuff like I don't
actually see that I've just been there
it's like fog
ofwar o I can go
upstairs going upstairs so far hasn't
really been great for me
why because there's never anybody up
there oh but sometimes there will be a
dude you're I always waste a lot of time
units scouting stuff which is okay you
shouldn't be scared to do that there
isn't like things for you to pick up
either right like you can like once
you've researched the alien Weaponry mhm
and like if you still have like a
regular gun and you can you can actually
pick up the alien guns and start using
them if you've if you've researched
them oh God
this guy's so slow and in the in the
beginning of the game your first mission
it's really going to be slow because you
don't have any time units really like
once you get up to about the 70 80 time
units that's when the game starts to
really flow does it take time units to
crouch yes three oh man how come your
guys aren't crouching Not Afraid well
they're not finished moving yet oh okay
I usually do like one move for everybody
and then I move everybody for yeah I'm
very very deliberate in my
movement even though it's not even
though I'm not actually the best get I'm
not actually super good at this game I
just enjoy it a
lot well that's you know that's that's
all that really matters I mean like if
you enjoy the game that's why it's worth
$25 for you right it's always about you
know what you're getting out of the game
like $25 to you for this game is worth
it it might not be to someone else but
that's why we're showing you the game
yeah you can decide for yourself and
also you know for some for some people
like you know even Bonito who's played
XCOM original and you see the the hype
and the joy that he's displaying in the
office that's really who I piging this
to like if you out there have played the
original XCOM and you like XCOM Enemy
Unknown but you felt like it was lacking
some of the original stuff this is the
game you were looking for and this was
the game I was looking for when Enemy
Unknown came
out okay now we're going to assault the
ship we're going to assault the ship
I'll show you how I do this I don't know
if this is actually the smartest way to
do this oh is that the shotgun guy the
front guy it's the shotgun guy knock
knock are there any aliens in
here so I guess while you're moving your
dudes like what are some of like the
things that this game did do better for
you that unknown didn't do I guess the
biggest thing for me was time units that
whole thing is that man that clock
management where you can move shoot move
Crouch you can't do that Enemy Unknown
Enemy Unknown is move shoot and you're
done except for the some of the perks
where you get another second shot maybe
but this game you can really decide what
your turn does like move shoot move
Crouch or Crouch shoot move yeah until
you're done with your time units okay
and that like opens up so many more
tactical like
possibilities so far been a pretty good
year for you huh for game for games yeah
not bad you're going to get Divinity
Divinity is coming next week yeah oh you
just got shot from behind from where
here yeah over there I was watching okay
so he's in the shadow see there's a guy
there you didn't look there's a guy
there I didn't
look I'll take blame I've been uh there
he is he's right there you oh my god see
that's how you die because you don't
look and he's like right there remember
Pro tip too always look guys always be
looking oh okay I'm I got cover though
so I'm just going to chill here if he
moves this guy's going to take a shot if
I think his reflexes
are 40 he's not GNA take the first
shot oh man what am I gonna do about
this
guy he's in like a precarious
position scoreback uh says is really is
Divinity really next week 30th 30th oh
that is yeah that's next week yeah
that's next Tuesday right hey dad looks
like we got it now playing
oh wow that's not a crit even right uh
no it would tell you right uh I know I
don't think it tells you it'll just be
like a bigger damage okay so what's
what's average damage then guess it
depends on guns right depends on the gun
and you can see it I think is that show
up here no it shows up in the in the map
screen
okay like when you're outfitting your
dude oh man these guys are going to die
why they're going to open the door and
shoot you gu well one of these guys well
I don't know we'll see we'll see what
happens oh you think he's going to
advance and like shoot you cuz you're an
open it's super possible man you're
going you're getting real bold here
sending four out in the open like that
yeah it's cuz I didn't know this guy was
here and these guys were already on the
way so it's like kind of too
late so now I'm saving all these time
unit to take shots at dudes that I don't
see so that's what I'm doing right now
the one your two guys that have them
pinned you have them there like set if
he moves to shoot at him or okay and
they're always on oh this guy doesn't
have any more time units to shoot cuz he
took a shot but this guy still has a
shot shot oh he can do a burst shot so
he if he does the right thing which
sometimes they don't
do he'll take a burst shot oh it's it's
at random which one he oh what how come
you don't get to decide and I think it
has something to do also with like each
different one has a different initiative
so like the faster ones will go first I
would just think it's based on your time
units and he should pick the most
efficient or the best see CU what
happens what happens is there's a
there's a there's a it's not a dice roll
it's a number check between his and your
initiative and it it looks at your
reflex number and I think the type of
shot also affects that number so it'll
choose based on like the best shot
according to that but sometimes that's
not the one I would take mhm but it's
the best shot okay so we're going to
Rend this turn and watch somebody die oh
no oh 82 I told you Jesus yeah that guy
didn't take a shot my dude didn't take a
shot good thing names have not been used
yet it's okay he's just my heavy machine
guy he always dies he's slow as [__]
okay now this guy's going to die now
this guy's going to die oh in the
face I should probably keep scouting
here because there might be more so you
probably crit him that last time if you
did 40 versus 22 there yeah that could
have that probably was could have
been I think sakatumi has been one of
the first people that says he wants to
be one of your okay your army your
definitely have a sakatumi in here
sakumi you got tell me what position you
want or like what I'm going open the
door all right here we goes bang oh oh
they're all dead no no there's someone
hiding oh [__] you're right they are all
dead how is that so how does that work
they just like died in the crash yeah
they died in the crash so what happens
what happened in the original XCOM one
of the things that they changed between
the old one and this one it was a slight
change where if you like really [__] the
plane up in the air with your with your
with your Scouts then there would be
very few survivors left because they'd
all be dead yeah um and that They
Carried that on to here but one thing
they had in the original was like the
ship would also be screwed so sometimes
there's like a back door that just got
opened up and you could go in from the
back or something like that like an like
a like I mean they might have added that
but I haven't encountered yet okay so
now my strategy is to hold the ship for
five
turns uh do different regions have
different bonuses what do you mean by
regions oh like perks and XCOM Enemy
Unknown guess no it's not like that they
just give you
money I found that was a little bit of a
crutch actually in the game
kilber also wants to be a member he
wants to be the shotgunner okay uh oh
[__] psychi wants to be a sniper or a
medic I don't think you have any medic
so it's going to be sniper well they all
they all like okay you can give them met
packs no one's an actual no one the
classes don't actually matter that's
just for your own like oh this guy's
going sniper all right so you assign
stuff like and you assign it based on
the numbers right the class is based on
numbers okay so I'm just going to run
these turns so I can take over this ship
unless another alien comes and then
we're going to take a little ad break
okay uh sheepa will take any position on
the team so that's three people four no
turns Bob Jones wants to be a machine
gun guy and one more turn this should be
it this should be it the guy's name that
I keep butchering wants to be Canon F so
once you win this is the
screen I only killed two of the three
aliens there's one more alien so that's
bad oh where's the he was hiding
somewhere man that bad cuz you're
supposed to kill them all but yeah I
might have lost another guy you know if
I went to look for him
Zen not casually is one so that's decent
surviving forces they killed a civilian
here's the money you take home some
alien Alloys then you need that to build
the Cassian non oh is that the civilian
or something what the destroyed what
what's up with the destroyed where those
under alien Alloys oh is that just the
stuff in the ship that got that's just
oh man you got the research now yeah a
lot stuff toarch get alien Tech there's
like your uh level up well not level up
each every Mission if you have like if
you hit people or kill things you'll get
stuff like this accuracy in time
units there you go that was a mission
that's how that looks and uh we'll be
right
back welcome back hello playing some uh
xenonauts AKA XCOM the next coming of
XCOM original there you go XCOM oh I
like
that uh I'm about to rename my dudes to
the dudes in chat so if you want to be
one of these dudes let me know Sak said
he wanted to be the sniper the sniper
yeah she proba said
anything Bob Jones wants to be a machine
guy [__] what was his name again Dolph
Winkler no not Dolph
Winkler will ma Falk oh you're gonna be
you're going to be a lady
saki classy one will Ma
faul I'm trying to remember everyone um
where are you oh he's not in a ship
trying my best guys she's in a ship what
the hell how come I can't rename you
Wilma uh
oh why do I only have what un assign
three oh come on is this a bug un
assigned three I have assigned six oh no
they're not back yet they're not back
yet they're not at home
Bas there you go okay now they're
back uh he has like nine spots and I
have like six or seven so we'll see what
we can get through guys also uh
apologies to the the Gamespot Chatters
uh I I bork that one also I'm trying to
get into the oh there we go chat finally
loaded if you have questions in gam swad
chat go for it too sorry I will catch up
on them
now uh who else who else uh so Bob Jones
wants to be a machine
gunner uh give them some ammo oh this is
another thing I forgot to do earlier was
load them up on grenades and whatnot I
don't need those you do need those I
know super neat I'm joking I'm joking
okay who else who else uh did I say Bob
Jones the machine gun guy Bob Jones
wants to be a heavy yeah I guess so
who's a good heavy
here 63
sure oh you're going to give him lmg
yeah he wanted to be heavy right
yeah I'll give him
those that's exactly what I think Bob
Jones would look
like um she PO said any
position
oh you do the Corporal well you can cuz
I removed it so I added it all right so
Shea said any
position kilber wants to be the shot
Gunner who who what's his name sorry so
she PO is anything who wants kilber
spell it k i l b
r and next just whatever it is oh wasn't
William FAL sakatumi yeah sniper right
oh what the hell did it not
save what the
what no not typ who would have knew that
retyping uh this is the hardest part of
the game guys again or something oh what
the
what yep getting trolled by the game oh
you have to hit enter so I only have to
put socket to me yeah okay we got to
redo those sorry guys okay now I know
that that is Bob Jones
shotgunners well it's one word but
whatever it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter uh shotgunner was kilber KL it
can be like sh k i l b r it's like
share and then she Poes
anyone you be other shotty okay
that all right uh no no uh oh just
Wy uh sorry o Wy yeah there you go uh I
think scrollback said he would be Canon
fod hopefully that was accurate okay I'm
going to make you Canon fod uh what's
what's the
other
shoot affinati wanted to be a affen oh
God I butchered his name like several
times already today uh crap I don't know
what he wanted to be oh he wanted to be
Canon
FL a fanina AI n a TI how do you say
that I've said it two different ways and
they both wrong it could be either way
sir Twinkie wants to be a
Rifleman and if you have any spot left I
got one more I got no more spots that's
I'm sorry guys it's because that one
person died don't wor someone's going to
die no are are these all your unassigned
or is this just your assigned these are
just the assigned okay the unassigned
guys like there's still two more all
right but we'll see if they get play you
know okay we don't know if they can all
right sorry guys wait till one of wait
till one of your fellow compatriots dies
okay so we got to do all this stuff oh
my new scientist 7 arve yet oh grubber
888 I'm sorry I missed that we'll try to
get you in as a sniper next time yes I
can make my Scout car little tank these
are great in the early game all right
let's kill some
aliens also you see these little things
like little blips of stuff that's
happening oh around the world but I I
don't actually know I just those are
like news
reports they don't have you don't have
talentry or anything right it's just
skill points or whatever or just not
even skill points it's just your stat
points stat points yeah it's all stats
and guns stats and gear PT flea I'll try
to get you in there if anyone dies
apologies oh someone's going to die okay
well there you go you heard it from
Bonito first there will be deaths oh I
got my car okay so my Scott car is
finished it's the little tank thing mhm
and I like that is that fast is that is
that just for you to intercept uh no no
that's in the ground combat oh there's
ground combat too so I usually take six
dudes in a tank and that thing just goes
around and kills things well you control
it well yes but I mean you get do they
get vehicles uh there are yeah they have
vles oh man all right their vehicles are
deadly all right all right so I'm going
to put you in the ship okay just just
anybody who's about to play this game it
took me a little while to get used to
finding where everything is like putting
stuff in the ships like drop ship
assignment that's how you put them in
the ships it was just took me a little
while I'm also kind of a
I like to look at everything so there it
is that's how everything looks so then
now that I have a tank I like to put the
tank out front
obviously because tank okay so tanks are
good in that they're strong they fire a
lot and they have a lot of action points
but they don't gain XP and they take
away XP essentially from it yeah so
there's that but but you don't have to
use it you survive so that's the most
important part but I mean technically
you don't necessarily have to use it to
kill things right you don't have to yeah
you don't have to if if you if the
situation presents itself where you can
win without it actually oh [__] okay and
I hope you all die I'm just kidding we
don't want to fail on stream two again I
also forgot to be building
hangers you still researching we need
more
ships oh are those going to be like your
backups or wait can you have four
there's multiple man can you have four
jet fighters yeah you can have as many
as you have hangers oh man yeah it's
time to get the migs
out even though we're not
Russian oh over the ocean again uh are
tanks damaged by normal fire yes okay
but they have a lot of armor so they
resist a lot of damage and can you also
use it for uh cover yes nice that's
actually a tactic I use as
well take the pistol because pistol you
don't see it there's no tree there's no
skill tree I'm sure there's one online
but in game there's no skill tree okay
um but it tells you here kind of what
it'll lead to stud of this may improve
your armor so there I want my pistol is
going to improve your armor research not
the pistol oh I guess cuz then you'll
know how against it I guess you don't
get the gun I w't get that why
not the first time I oh I want plasma
right away hell yeah it's that like it's
like the M gun it's that little MV gun
that you have to research alien plasma
rifle to lead to laser guns and then
later on it you have to research
fabrication of plasma guns yeah yeah
yeah there's all that varant we'll try
to get you in there too we'll see we're
we've got about probably one more battle
I know probably one more that's why I
said four hours stream man got to be
stream it's fine I got to buy we're
giving them a taste you showed them
Condor what it's like to fight in the
air do you get to upgrade the your
aerial fighting ability you can all that
happens too so here every year uh this
happens and it shows you your budget for
for the year and that's how much money
you got how much money you spend every
year and then how much you money you
have left the US what are they doing
they don't are you doing America I don't
no yeah no they hate me they hate me I
know but like I'm looking at their
monthly change man they spent they're
negative they're in the red 150 that's
how much they're giving me oh they're
giving you this is how much money
they're all giving me because they're
all paying me to defend the world from
Aliens right I thought that was like
you're how you're doing compared to the
rest of the world that's how much money
that they're giving me how much money
those governments are giving me and
since I I'm in the middle I guess I'm
I'm technically in the Middle East
section are you no you're not
technically oh I guess yeah yeah yeah
okay geography guys
geography even though that's over here
whatever yeah it's close enough it's
within your radar where is this guy okay
I need to put this guy off how come you
only have two planes I thought you made
two more no I ordered two more still on
way oh they're still on the way all
right I saw you plopped them down in
your your hangers I thought they were
done I put it in order I only put it in
order oh dud aren't back
yet oh they're oh
[__] see that one landed you see that oh
it's too late but it went landed so my
ships couldn't kill it so he landed my
ship circled around ran out of fuel went
back and then he took off up so when
when that happens when that happens you
need to send your drop ship down to go
kill him at the exact same time yeah
while while your planes circling above
so if he tries to escape then you shoot
it down okay does all that kind of [__]
so was that just because you fast
forwarded too fast or something you can
react
yeah oh there my my planes are in all
right guys I want to see a vote of who
is going to actually who you guys think
is actually going to die on this next
mission see now I have two fights going
on so your guys split up there or no
there I I my two ples came your extra
ones came
four okay and now I don't want to stand
out to the trash site yet cuz as you see
it's night time and you don't want to
fight in the night time at least in the
early game you don't want to fight in
the night time just cuz they can see and
you have low visibility that can't be
that
bad my D set my D
oh and this is probably a noob question
if you have uh like two drop ships and
you have two crash sites would you only
manage one at a time right yeah yeah you
can only fight one but you can send two
drop ships to a thing so you can
actually have up to 16 dudes out on the
field which I imagine you will have to
do later on in the bigger missions
interesting
okay you haven't gotten to that point
right where you used to not there yet
I'm not even in in any missions where I
need more than six in a tank
yet who is going to die who's going to
die who is going to
die don't forget your pro tips always be
crouching always look around jper thinks
uh Bob Jones is going to die Ry from
games chat thinks the it's going to be a
wipe I'm going to tell you whoever chose
the shotgun guy you're probably going to
die cuz you're up front well here's the
tank re monkey saying the tank will die
there you go see this is the original
XCOM style where you just step out of
the thing and they shoot at you that's
why you send the tank out that's why you
send the tank out first and that's why
you go out the side
doors well they could be off to the side
there there too oh man always look guys
Pro tip number
two see these guys are militia Guys
these guys are on our side but you don't
control them always be looking you might
even want to look at that back well I
guess if there's militia guys there
there won't be anyone yeah they'll shoot
at them that's cool with
me who should I shoot I guess I should
shoot at this guy because he's I don't
know do you really want to shoot them
though yeah yeah I want to okay you
don't want that
ex oh my goodness Overkill you can't
risk that kind of [__] because you're
going to die man that doesn't even seem
fair
that doesn't even seem fair have you
ever lost your tank yeah okay easily
fair enough fair
enough oh there's the ship it's right
there awesome but I bet you there's a
dude or two over here eminent stranger
thinks that we're going to Prevail no
deaths we'll
see uh zeni has a question are they
planing to add multiplayer I don't think
so I I don't see how you could add
multiplayer into this game cuz it's turn
based and uh especially in the the
geoscape map it's like you're
controlling the time so I don't know if
how that would
work unless it's like versus multiplayer
I guess like some Enemy Unknown but I
feel like that was tacked on in Enemy
Unknown
uhuh oh God I have no time units these
guys are all going to die scrollback
says I wish I knew the tank was an
option when I signed up for for the
Xenon team no you can't you can't rename
the tank oh there's no dude in there
it's a drone it's all right drones can
have names I guess
so man
die so the ship's what top right is that
what that thing
is the ship yeah
yep oh God you shoot through the window
no I shouldn't stand there I should not
stand there oh this guy's goingon to die
Bob Jones sorry Bob
joneson you're the one that's going to
die so there's no
takebackspace guys bling the door
[__] always look always look oh is that
the edge of the map though yeah this is
the edge of the map you can tell by like
you know this little
circle that's important to figure out
also like where the edge of the map is
yeah there it
is I got two shy guys that's
right attacking the ship you
will hi well Jones says they're killing
me
off not on
purpose know if mistake is just as
good oh God okay this is this I feel
like right side contingent is is in a
good shape well yeah they're going to
attack the ship so you need the four
Dudes over there these two dudes are
going to kill this one guy who I I hope
is the only guy left
outside oh that's fine you can shoot the
militi militia yeah shoot the
militia oh he's going to fight back oh
oh wow snip sniper oh double shot oh he
didn't die that's fine he's going to die
in this next
shot oh it's cuz he's
exposed he's left himself vulnerable oh
here comes Bob Jones Bob Jones doesn't
have enough time units you didn't want
can aat can make it all
right what is 0% chance blocked I'm
blocked see the red yeah the the the
wall it tells you what blocks you that's
pretty cool too I like that I think
you're still blocked right
yeah got to one square over it's it's
only get a SN I only get a snot yo this
isn't going to make it really I'm not
going to hit him oh my goodness I don't
think I'm going to hit dude he's 88%
though or wait how come 22 because okay
it's 22 to take the shot but if you have
to also slightly look a little bit more
that's more time units so like yeah
sorry aady you're about to die oh we got
we could have our first death here and
it wasn't Bob Jones Bob has lived to
find another day if the tank can make it
through then he can
survive no wish I can also take this
shot because you can take down the Walls
there is destruc
Levolution all right destructive
environments oh I can't make it through
there there's no space come on you can
shoot me through there dude wide load
wide load can you break the B you can
break the fence see like that but I
don't have enough time you oh no okay
okay now for real someone's going to
die okay it could be the tank let's just
assault the ship for
now ignore this one dude down here is
about to
kill oh man that's about to happen he
said oh crap Canon pot for the win
that's about to
happen oh this guy might die too [__]
that's my
bad okay let's let's see what
happens oh he Sho get the
civy death to unknown person what was
that how come he's a different color
he's just wearing a different shirt man
oh it's not like Time Crisis the red guy
is more uh czy might he could be always
shoot the red guys now this guy's
goingon to die now this guy's goingon to
for sure die I hope you're right B oh
aanti with the first
kill all right this guy's going to for
sure die too or do I want to shotty in
the face we want some Shea you want some
shotty in the
face I'm guessing shotty does more
damage yeah it shoots three bullets oh
three like three times or just three oh
[__] wrong dude at least he
hit it was planned it was planned it was
to ensure the death oh you didn't even
open the sh no one died no one no cuz
everyone's dead that's boring nobody
died come on civilians died civilians
died all right who called the who called
the oh Emin eminent stranger coming up
big you just never know how many aliens
there going to be you know this one
there was only three so jper
66666 4 sixes says letting the civilians
take the fall huh Bonito not cool yep
not cool hey such's
life if you're unarmed you're going to
die well he was armed actually but not
sure if this is factually correct but
venti says right guys are red shirts
which are Canon fod I don't know oh red
shirts because of uh Star Trek uh uh
okay I thought red shirt was like isn't
that what Bard wears though Bard wears
red he wears a red shirt but like this
is this goes back to the sh old school
days always extra dude at the end you're
coming with us private he's red shirt
and he's going to die okay that's all
happens before my time okay before my
time I'm I'm next Generation I'm
actually not I'm not a start Trek fan
but I know that much I know that
much some research
called it what do you win you win a nice
little clap see you get to survive to
the next Battle Is What You Get Well
eminence's not part of the team he's
just a cheerleader he's a he's a he's
one of the guys at base that's not
named that won't ever see the light of
day oh yeah ocelot not yeah ocelot snake
snake where you at he's
far scramble the the
fighters to your
right oh he lost
me what's that a scout
ship wow man you're your jet fighters
yeah cuz I'm sending two that's in the
beginning I was only sending one it kept
SC my shift I was controlling it no no
no the other time unless it's because
low ammo it might have been a bigger
ship oh was low ammo were you were on uh
knocking on death's door figure our
dudes here real quick oh oh yeah they
all survived so you all get to go and
live another day and fight again all
let's do it this is probably your last
engagement I'm assuming unless we do the
4our stream I know we can't do that cuz
we have Sniper Elite got Sniper Elite
coming up at 2 o'clock if you're
interested in that game we got Chris
Waters doing
that I think this game needs background
music says dan oh it does have
background music do you not hear it is
it just low oh I might have killed it
because I usually play my own
music uh oh no there's there's music
just very low it's probably one of those
games where it's not too much noise
until you you move yourself right more
very atmospheric music it's
like all
right uh varti says red are
non-combatant and xenonauts blue are
guards blue and black Are Soldiers then
it's a bit more that's great to know how
do you know all this stuff who knows
reny who are you have you been playing
this game I like
you so now we need to guess who's going
to actually die
here these missions scare me cuz I
didn't see anybody coming out of the
ship so I don't know which way to go
it's very the map seems way bigger than
the last couple Maps you've been on too
this one goes that way I'm in the bottom
left corner so I got to go this way you
don't even see the ship
right oh man all right remember Pro tip
number two always look always be
looking and hope you have enough uh
turns to uh Crouch There You Go Pro tip
number one save three always save three
so so the extension of pro tip one is
always save three so you can Crouch
that's how you do rule number one always
save
three people are saying rip cannon
fodder
Bob Jones dies or
Riot where's Bob Jones which one's Bob
Jones Shea doesn't feel good about this
uh this Mission
here okay I think uh let's see some
aliens so you they're going to come oh
right into the wall brilliant the what
is that that is like a spider sense no
it's like a nerve I think it's one of
that's an alien ability which decreases
their bravery so if if they do that
enough they start freaking out and run
away and drop their weapons and that
kind of [__] can you shoot your own
people you can you can totally shoot
your own people it's like Russia there's
no turning back always
forward Ah that's not even fair
bam that's not even fair totally fair I
hope the aliens have a a tank cuz dude
you don't want to like I don't know if
we'll see it but aliens have like a
little disc like like the disc in Enemy
Unknown it's the same oh really fires
like 10 shots nice we need to see one of
those it's over here whoever
asking it's over here
Chris yeah we you know trying to help
production and Chris W find a find his
hard cop of Sniper Elite which is right
there in a nice happening at 2 p.m. with
tin metal K going
to there you go there he is see Sniper
Elite we're going to see crotch shots
head shot shot Hitler in the balls shots
what else is there th shot what else is
there why would you try to Breaking of
Bones shredding of
muscles for the time being we're going
to watch Bob Jones po Jones is going to
die like is that is that what they want
do they want that to happen cuz I can
make that happen that's easy no I think
you should play it out and if if he dies
he you don't want to no sacrificial s
here for no
reason everyone's got to do their job
everyone fights no one
quits got to move slowly or you're going
to
die the tank doesn't move very far huh
well I save a lot cuz he takes 35 to
shoot oh me so he can take two shots if
he doesn't move gotcha so nothing
happened there nothing happened well
nothing that I know of happened take a
browse got four more points before I can
I guess I just have to
move what that what was that I don't
even see him I don't even see him can
you can you there he is oh is he on the
ledge he's behind it oh okay can you
blow that I don't I don't think I have I
don't think I can blow this thing up I
don't think I maybe not even with Gran I
don't have anything strong enough
grenades maybe maybe let's
see you guys want to see test IAL shots
I don't know if they actually can't okay
I'm assuming Chris is probably doing the
Sniper Elite um
review most likely maybe if there's
enough guns maybe he can do a gun show
who
knows I'm putting words and work in his
mouth you're giving Chris Waters work
yeah
sure so right now I have this position
so oh does he have enough yeah yeah so
like if he tries to take a shot at
somebody or tries to move here he's
going to get shot by this guy by sakat
this guy or she and no not this guy that
kver kind of holding the other flank but
you don't know what's on the other side
though I don't I really
don't this guy's going to find out
aanati oh there you go sacrificial lamb
enough time to crouch sorry got to find
out if there's any bad
guys oh God I can't make it all the way
oh God I hait that that's the
worst aren't you like kind of exposed
there well I guess you can Crouch cover
yeah but if he comes from the if he
comes from there yeah I'm [__] I guess
that's the east of have this guy look
that way make sure there's nobody there
okay yeah there's nobody there so you
can't see past those walls huh these
things yeah yeah line sight it's a very
big
thing this is a huge map I don't I don't
like your tank positioning no I like my
tank position you need him out the open
so that's what they shoot at bait the
bait yeah yeah but I feel like you think
think it's going to be North is where
the I think it's going to be North it's
usually in the opposite corner from
where you're at but it could be also
just like on the opposite side from
where you're at but it's usually pretty
far away from your ship it's usually on
the other side of
something I think you're just going to
chill out you're just going to chill out
scroll back I want to make this comment
that Bry says but I don't know if it's
PC oh
okay they're telling you not to send
scroll back first let's just put it that
way you got to think about that you
think about why that happens and why he
might be the first to die I'll be subtle
about
it it's okay my Tank's killing
everything and nobody's going to gain XP
today that's where's the fun in that
Shea get in there shotgun to the face
yeah shapa can give him a shotgun to the
face but if there's a dude here he's
[__] well sometimes sometimes you got
to take one for the T all right
shapa give him one to the face give to
the face I'm this is pretty probably
another dumb question it's like if you
put a guy behind shipa and you try to
shoot the alien it's going to hit shipa
right no if he's like right behind him
then it considers it to be like you can
shoot around him but if it's a square a
square away then you have to shoot
through him wow okay so right behind is
okay but one square behind is just
anywhere anywhere further than that it's
not not okay okay and if you want to see
what that looks like see if I want to
shoot this guy it'll oh no no I can't I
can't do it right I'm guessing aliens
can't get in your ship right no they can
oh they can what happens what happens
nothing they can't blow it up or
anything all right Chapa take the shot
19 oh you can take two you can take two
double tap one you better die you better
die it's like the zombie killing yeah
there you
go Shea did
work you're not afraid that someone's on
further east there I mean there's a
weird like timing feel that you get in
this game where like you pretty much
feel like there's no one left outside
sometimes I'm wrong remember that guy in
The Dump you remember the guy in the
dumpster and you're like where did that
come from sometimes I'm wrong but most
of the time I'm
right so you go with your gut yeah yeah
I go with a gut I go with a gut which
probably isn't the smart way to go
but George W bush
style think with my gut think with my
gut I don't know how I feel about that
but all
right now I'm just assulting the ship so
just move everybody
forward hoping that got better at this
game because man usually when I restart
games like d just keep dying stream good
lucks man sometimes when you when you're
on the stream the luck travels with you
so captain scrollback man in the back
here Corporal Corporal
sorry I hope there's aliens come on
aliens come on there's got to be like
five look at how big big that ship
is imagine I I imagine they're probably
all dead if they haven't do they do they
wait for you have you have you is that a
scenario or they for they're in the ship
they wait for you but they will come out
yeah we saw that last last mission yeah
I mean in the beginning when I was
playing this game they never came out so
I was like I'm just going to put
everybody in front of the door before I
go in save everybody's time just keep
running turns and then go in but then
one time this one dude came out and just
like killed everybody I was like oh I
guess I gotta do that mow them down
oh man maybe you should have just named
it the streamers from the get-go and
that first person might not have even
died maybe
maybe you're not even going to crouch
those guys you're not going to crouch
those guys or you can't this guy's going
to crouch oops two guys in front these
two yeah
sure come on you got to follow your own
Pro tips you can't we can't give Pro
tips and then not do them no I'm talking
I I that rule is for noobs like in the
beginning of this game just make sure
that you always Crouch so you understand
the importance of crouching but it's not
necessarily you have to crouch all the
time well I mean you're going to get
your you get your your your turns back
then after it Cycles right like you to
Max right so like it if you use them all
but it also takes three turns to stand
up so in your next turn it Tak three
extra three extra units to move fair
enough fair
enough you just post up all
right from inside their mind effing you
what is going on here they like to do
s come on are we going to have to shoot
together sake are we going to have to
shoot you for INS
subordinates 84% with a machine gun Bob
Jones can take you out right
now Bob you stay on the trigger saki
does anything funny you know what to do
oh [__] that's the wrong guy oh no it's
fine oh [__] that guy's a sniper SN
going in with a sniper no
MLG status here no scope got hang out
there so there's no way for you to like
boost morale or to calm him
down not yet but I'm I'm pretty sure
there probably is you got to be like
also like the more you kill stuff the
more confident your guy gets so then you
don't get as as scared as fast like you
can see like I have this guy has 96
bravery right now all right she 35 85 76
you got to be like uh the the robo arm
guy in in uh
freaking Starship Troopers nobody
doesn't listen to him cuz he'll shoot
you oh there three of hey there's a is
that pink dude pink or purple venti what
is the pink purple dude the fuchsia you
did not warn me about the pink fuchsia
guy oh man no the 4-Hour stream won't
happen mainly because we have Sniper
Elite later this is probably last
mission
here man this is rough see there's
another there's another little tactic I
use here which I didn't figure out until
later I'll show you oh come on show you
when the turn's almost
over how far have you gone in the game
says your your friend that's my friend
Chuck it's okay we're blocking it we're
blocking see
it suppressed yeah so that means he
takes he has less action points in the
next turn his next turn you can blow I'm
guessing you can blow that up right the
little thing he's hiding behind oh yeah
if if you hit here shoot it oh he's just
dead but if you miss him and you hit the
and you hit the cover it starts to get
degraded and then eventually it dies oh
don't die Shea you got to you got to
level up from this this he's Shea's got
two kills
man see that minus see that 25% right
there
underneath 45% no no underneath this
dude underneath kilber oh because you
might hit him that's that's that's the
chance to hit him oh kilber you're going
to be a innocent bystander potentially
yeah sorry kilber I got to shoot through
you real quick oh
man oh Matrix
did I'm G to I got to take another one
too so okay he's goingon to do it
again no no oh he's mad he's kilber is
going to take actions into his own hands
I'm sorry
affan fair is fair right I can make him
shoot back but he might die dude a
shotgun all right
fine okay so this is my tactic right
here so just close the door they can't
shoot they can open the door but if they
open the door then I shoot at him see
okay okay so that's you move up your
other guys yeah well they can't you feel
like you feel like they're okay they
don't have time you don't want to have
one guy like guarding the door in near
other Rock there this one that yeah that
one then that mean the sniper has to
shoot through him
uh trying to get saaki killed is really
what I'm trying to do
here well I'll move I moved him up so
now he has a better shot CH says save me
Bonito oh
unnerved all right cobber is
bleeding oh [__] somebody needs to patch
him up he's not a medic's who's got the
Medics this guy all right scrb going in
to patch him
up kilber says I quit I'm off the
team I heit you you're all good now well
not all he wasn't you can't you can't
see you can't get back all your hit
points your
okay I missed the chat but he said don't
do it when you took the
shot and the first one he was like thank
God and then when he got hit he said I
quit oh man okay watch this kill you're
going to be a superstar right here oh in
the
face 13 I have two of these oh I can do
two of these somebody asked what the
game was yes it is like a spiritual
successor to the original
XCOM oh no still alive you're hard he's
bleeding though he's going to bleed out
cuz you got to heal earlier man if you
didn't get that heal he'd be okay
another thing for you to to learn cuz uh
verenti seems to be very knowledgeable
about aliens here is that the pink guy
is the one doing the psychic attacks oh
there you go giving you the the Mind FS
is what that guy is doing Pro tips jper
wants you to kill
Bob um what happened to the tank it
can't I'm guessing you can't really use
it in this scenario right I kind of can
but the thing is when you're inside the
ship you don't want to use explosives or
the tank in there
you want to keep as much of this intact
as possible there you go good good
reasoning there what I usually do is I
like keep them outside just in case
they're still dud outside like watching
everybody's back oh SCS still got that
out somebody needs to finish this guy
off sack uh oh no Take that can you
Matrix it can you Matrix it one more
time won't take the shot it's only a 19%
though but no I won't all right look at
that the captain or the the colonel or
the commander here is looking out for
his his his peoples kilber says please
save
me okay okay he guess what okay okay
okay oh no I to close the door on sheep
ho I forgot to close the door sheep hoe
no oh kilber is dead isn't he oh no
kilber is going to save the day right
here oh [__] what are you doing oh he
ran away he's at one life can you save
him he ran away see I have control over
does he bleed out does he bleed out at
one life or is it like he can bleed out
but I will sa I will save him I will
save I thought you already used oh you
have more pack
oh is that how much it heals for too uh
it heals for how many action points you
spend on it okay so 27 oh kilber you're
lucky Bonito is a a kind soul sir twinky
said rip kilber that didn't happen shapa
is gonna be the Superstar then yeah well
Shea already killed two people so this
would be the third kill I expect big
level UPS here damn game it's game all
right promoted look at that you're
Sergeant now promoted injured for 14
days though yeah you're out of action is
is that yeah I think that's about time I
mean like if there's anything you want
to showcase or wrap up before um pretty
much saw the game that's like all the
levels of the game there's the Tactical
combat part there's the base building
part there's the research part there's
building stuff part there's the RPG part
yeah and there's the resource management
part so there's a lot of games in this
game that's one of the reasons why I
love this game it's like there's like
basically six games in here that all
actually connect to form one game oh is
that just your yeah this is just the
little I'm guessing you get like
upgraded tanks and airships right yes
all that stuff I actually already
upgraded the
ship UPG a new ship I think let's see
yeah there the Fox Trot Interceptor
that's the Mig 200,000 but those only
have uh missiles so okay if they fight
against Fighters they just get
screwed so that was uh that's Xenon nuts
I feel like I'm the only one excited
about this game but I shouldn't be I
just so if definitely some other people
so if you're into the old school escom
and hard games just like hard technical
games in general this is probably for
you um because it was for me